you alejandro yes we are indeed with a
very happy victor of today's final round
aram hakobian representing webster
university aram welcome back to the show
yesterday unfortunately a big loss for
you it felt like you were playing for a
victory in this event unfortunately you
were sidetracked by that loss but now
you bounce back with a clean victory how
does that feel how do you assess your
tournament also well it feels of course
great to finish the tournament with the
victory
to be honest i was not really in a
fighting mood today
but uh well he played c5 first move so i
was like okay let's go for it
and oh i mean the tournament of course i
was expecting more
i i mean i wanted to win the tournament
but
i was not in my best physical shape and
i was tired like probably from round
five i was not playing
a good chat at all but i was still doing
fine yeah i was making draws but i was
not happy with my play at all but i
think today i played the decent game
more or less so i'm i'm quite happy
about it yeah did you neglect the
physical preparation before the event
why do you say that you're feeling a bit
tired well i didn't i didn't do sports
as much as i had to
yeah understood let's go through the
game and actually see how you punished
let's say your opponent in this final
round alejandro yeah it felt like he was
also in a fighting mood and he he really
played this i always felt this was
dubious the straight-up tube used to
force white to take on f6 in this
position i know it's played yeah i think
h6 was played by
against devon of course with the queen
on h8 right i actually have this game up
here and just to show oh
i think that actually works just to show
the audience of what can happen
i'm not sure if i was following the
exact game but i was i i could remember
the ideas so i was doing pretty much the
same
uh yeah with uh and this is the
adventure game where
i this always caused a great impression
on me oh okay yeah i didn't remember the
king h1 stuff yeah yeah because it's
very similar to your game right and it
always made an impression to me that
kasparov lost with a queen on on h8 at
some point right yeah because he never
does this i mean this this is the game
eventually kasparov always thought i
always felt this line cannot be good if
if a player like us power off is forced
to make the move queen h8 at some point
uh this was a brilliant brilliant win by
by ivan let me make sure that i didn't
mess up the entire
setup yeah i did not do amazing you
didn't ah
yeah so i was quite happy to see h6 i i
was just trying to remember
how the game went so
uh yes we got slightly off track but it
also feels that your bind was very
strong that you were playing very well
well yeah actually when i played b5 he
was quite surprised so at that point i
realized that he didn't see that game or
he just forgot
because b5 is actually very strong move
yeah you give the c5 square but the main
idea in this position that yeah after
chris seven
knight d2
queen c5 i think he played queen d3
let's say if he goes b6
and i go knight d1 i think
the best move and that then my idea is
to go knight e3
and knight b3 and then sacrifice with c5
and put my knight on c4 and this just
deadly
lost
but bishop d8 was was an interesting try
i think his best chance was go to garuk
g8 first
um because now if i go 91 maybe he has
bishop d8 here
so i wasn't sure what i was going to do
but obviously even after rook j8 i'm
still the one who is pushing yeah yeah
um so he played bishop d8
i'm not sure if he saw e5 i don't know
but
probably didn't see the e5 yeah it's a
cool movie yeah it is a cool move but
it's kind of hard for me to believe that
he missed d5 yeah this clear and
sacrifice with the knight arriving on e4
which is going to be so deadly what was
his body language
i i couldn't tell
is always sitting very confidently so
it's hard to say you know
uh but i think he was planning to go d5
but d5 is pretty bad because i mean i
can probably even go knight e4 or rook
ad1
yeah but this looks good yeah it's just
then the queen e5 i think rook d1
i mean i'm not sure if this was working
but
probably it's not actually yeah because
rook c7 b6 no rook 7b6 but maybe he has
castle
oh castle in this position yeah and if i
take bishop c7 but
yeah it starts getting a little messier
than yeah i mean okay after d5 i can
just go rook d1 and it's it's just
terrible position i think
keep it simple yeah this looks very bad
he plays f5 actually the engine thought
it was the best move
yeah probably
it takes bishop f6 uh rook d1 and we
don't really care about this dubious it
feels like you have such a uh
such a strong advantage in this position
no i was sure that i'm not playing the
best moves that's the thing
um yeah especially here i think queen f3
was immediately better
of three here and if um
let's say b6
and i go queen f4
and now i wanna go queen h4
and you know i control this squares e7
and the knight f6 check is coming
and
probably has to go queen d4 here as well
but it's the better version what i got
in the game
what you got in the game was pretty good
yeah
it just feels like you have a very
consistent bind for the rest of the game
no matter what he does right
i think he did not he did not play the
best way he had to go bishop c8 i think
instead of bishop c3 all the way back
here
uh no i mean bishop c3 was correct
rook e3 bishop b4 i think was also fine
knight f3
maybe here he has to go bishop c8
here in this position yeah
and uh rook d3 and bishop b7
i'm very bad though and then you attack
my my you know rook with bishop e4 so it
was kind of annoying still do i but yeah
i mean of course
somehow has to be winning
yeah yeah yeah this is not this is not
clean at all because d6 hangs up maybe
rook d4
instead of and bishop c5 and now i'm
just planning on giving you my rook uh
if possible i don't know if that's
possible or not maybe with d7 yeah
yeah d7 you're gonna pick up my the
problem is that you also have some ideas
of f6 at some point which are kind of
annoying which is funny thing is i don't
know if they work yeah that's not like
e6 i know we're going to carry it away
but this is a check right right also
knight c6 works there
96 here right yeah yeah this should also
work out yeah yeah he's winning
yeah probably you're right this is the
way yeah but it was still i mean the way
how he played was
i mean just
it was kind of easy for me to win
doesn't give himself any counter chances
yeah but it was it was very picturesque
i particularly liked this last little
detail at the end of uh why is it so bad
like nobody cares well rooksy five wins
that's why oh rooks if i was just yeah i
just repeat it to gay to get the 40 move
move 40 you know yeah uh no but i really
like this move uh f4 i thought it was
very cute
so yeah if he takes on f4
um yeah rook to seven wins
we're going to decide yeah we're
calculating knight c5 but this also
probably yeah c2 rook c1
rook d4 rook c7
and it's kind of cute way too king f2
yeah yeah and here again the importance
of the loft
uh you could take on c7 doesn't matter
i'll promote a pawn but this is just
hopeless because the rook defends the
queening square
how do you assess uh your tournament
overall i'm sure that you had ups and
downs
uh you said that you had prepared quite
a bit for this event and you are a
surging player you've done amazing in
many tournaments in the recent past
crossing that 2600 uh how do you feel
the performance here was
well it was i guess overall not bad
because
i gained some rating uh i finished plus
one and many many good players
didn't even get that plus one
um but obviously i want more
so i hope in the next event i would do
better you have a lot of fans both here
as well as in your home country over
media what's next for you in terms of
events
next i don't really know but i might
play the american cup bliss tournament
i'm really excited for that one i will
remind you you have a tournament before
that on april 2nd
well uh it was a pleasure seeing you
play all your amazing games we're
looking forward to commentating on your
games potentially at the american cup
thank you well thank you aram for
showing us some fantastic chess
certainly a surging player and it's
always good to see talent come here to
st louis whether it's to saint louis
university or to webster university we
have a lot of collegiate players here
that are just showing us the best that